ich mag sehr gern ich mag ihn einmal
gegen rechte vor bin ich gezwungen der
fi briest wieder zu lesen ja ich hab
damals musste ich das lesen da muss man
ja alles alles alles interpretieren und
das ist ja in der schule immer ein
bisschen mühsam fontane glaube ich
eignet sich für die schullektüre weil er
ist ja ein sehr handwerklich arbeitende
auto es gibt ein ganz komplexes system
von symbolen verweisen ja vorwegnahmen
da habe ich gesagt ja natürlich hast du
das gerade gesagt nicola soll ich nach
hause gehen weil ich einfach nicht
liefern kann was ich mache und ich
wollte nur darauf hinweisen dass das
buch natürlich für die schule
prädestiniert weil man herrlich fragen
kann was bedeutet denn hier die platane
wofür steht die schaukel und hat keine
schulden aber wenn er war der beste der
klasse musste alles das was
normalerweise ich sagen würde er war die
ober streberin sie sagen ich ein jammer
dass ich nicht zu sagen wenn der schule
waren wollen du warst doch fünf klassen
über mir weil ich die übersprungen habe
es ist die geschichte einer jungen frau
die gegen ihren willen verheiraten will
sie wird einfach sorgen soll geheiratet
und zwar mit dem ehemaligen liebhaber
der mutter was ich ja schon schändlich
finden und dann muss sie mit ihnen in
einem städtchen ziel namensketten wo er
als landrat arbeitet und da ist er
wahnsinnig langweilig und der uns ist
diese unzufriedenheit auch die
motivation für sie dann eine affäre
anzufangen mit major von crampas der
übrigens noch älter ist die affäre
findet dann aber ihr ende als sie mit
ihrem mann nach berlin zieht und dann
einige jahre später findet der baron
liebesbriefe aus dieser affäre und dann
enden alle tot und oder unglücklich aber
die botschaft ist immer die das ist
nicht möglich irgendjemanden hier eine
schuld an zu helfen das schult
eigentlich ein in adäquates prädikat ist
das gerät aber seine ansetzung von der
geschlechter ist das ja eine brennende
frage was ist ein plädoyer dafür dass
man den standpunkt ändert und die
blickrichtung ändert und das ist schön
man kann das buch einfach mit freude
ließ
wo er recht hat hat er recht ende
[Musik]